the games of the 32nd olympiad are
awarded to the city of tokyo
in july 2020 billions of people will
watch the olympic flame burn once again
as the tokyo olympics begin
but with new rules making it easier for
transgender women to compete in women's
events for the first time
2020 could turn out to be a highly
controversial olympic games
there's a heated debate in women's
sports over the inclusion of transgender
women
people who are biologically male and
identify as women
this is about are trans women actually
women
and it's clear that legally and socially
we are so
why exclude us from sport this isn't
about saying to someone
you can't live your life as a
transgender woman but you can't just
ignore the fact that biology
is something that as humans we have
international olympic committee rules
currently allow
transgender women to compete in women's
sports
provided they have suppressed their
testosterone levels for at least
12 months but some observers like former
olympic swimmer and medalist
sharon davies argue these athletes will
have an unfair advantage
you're not going to be able to get rid
of the male puberty that they've gone
through
the fact that they have male biology so
even by reducing testosterone for one
year
it's still not going to level the
playing field
but others take a very different view
like track cyclist
rachel mckinnon who has become a
high-profile transgender athlete
since winning a world championship in
2018.
athletes come in a huge range of shapes
and sizes
and natural abilities population
demographics around the world are
different so dutch women
average height is over five foot six
indonesian women is around four foot
ten so sport is never level if by which
we mean no one has a competitive
advantage over each other because that's
the
point of sport during male puberty
testosterone drives the development of
bigger muscles
with more fast twitching fibers sturdier
bones
and a larger heart and lungs all
lifelong advantages when it comes to
speed and strength
the difference between boys and girls
running times increases in adolescence
and the gap is even bigger for jumping
events
and in 2019 among top athletes
around 2000 men finished the 100 meters
more quickly
than the fastest woman
sharon davies believes there is a danger
that transgender athletes could dominate
some women sports
and that these sports could once again
be blighted by unfairness
in the 70s and the 80s we had the east
german system where
female athletes were filled full of
testosterone and it made them
unbeatable so for nearly a whole
generation the east german women totally
dominated
in almost all female sports at olympic
and world level but there are many
british that came
fourth and fifth and sixth and no one's
ever heard of them because they didn't
pick up a medal which they should have
done
so i feel quite passionately that i just
don't want to see that happen to a whole
generation of female athletes again
davies and others who have voiced their
concerns have faced strong criticism
from the transgender community and
beyond
you have been called by the transgender
cyclist rachel mckinnon
a transphobe and somebody who shares
hate speech
mckinnon argues the debate is
fundamentally about equality and human
rights
both on and off the playing field
inclusion is a fundamental principle in
society so i think that applies also to
sport
that applies to intersex women cis women
and trans women
that to be considered fully equal
members of society to be respected in
our identities
is to be included in sport for who we
are
and trans women are women
the ioc says it actively supports both
inclusion
and fairness it was due to announce
stricter guidelines for transgender
athletes in september 2019
but so far its panel of scientists have
failed to agree on what these should be
i think we need to race based on biology
so i think the very simple
straightforward way to race is based on
your chromosomes and if you carry a y
chromosome which gives you
a benefit a why benefit a male benefit
to your strength levels and your
testosterone levels
then you need to race where it's
apparent so we would should have
an xx female category protected and an
open category which is then inclusive
for absolutely everybody that wants to
be able to compete
so i just think there's ways forward
that doesn't mean the destruction of
female sport
while countries will be competing to
make their mark on the medal tables
the 2020 olympics could also prove to be
a decisive moment
in the wider global debate about gender
identity
thanks for watching if you'd like to see
more of our coverage on controversies in
sport
click the links opposite and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]